this is the Joo underground podcast it's
number
86 86 the term MH you you had that in
the in the what the bar Community the
nightclub Community that's Echo Charles
talking on the other
side did you ever get 86 from a bar I
have never been 86 I have never been
kicked out of a bar I've never been
anything yeah no I'm very I was always a
very well behaved uh Patron person Jack
all right well that makes one of us
So speaking of which I got asked by a
buddy of mine this
weekend if I didn't get assigned to Seal
Team 1 when I graduated
buds would I be
different and I just wrote back you he
was texting me and I wrote back
yes so the basis of the question
is and you may have heard me talk about
this back in the
day otherwise no back in the day and
it's not like this anymore Seal Team One
used to be known as Stog team one and
the reason they called it that was
because it was the most militant
team on the west coast anyways it had
uniform inspections it had haircut
inspections it was kind of like the
equivalent of SE Team 2 on the East
Coast which is the second team that I
went to and there's a reason why I
wanted to go to Seal Team 2 when I left
Seal Team one but he he knew me this is
this is a friend of mine that was also
in the Navy but it's someone that who I
knew growing up we knew we were
childhood friends so he understood the
Navy he understood the differences he'd
actually been to Coronado understood you
know the Navy understood understood that
the different teams had different
cultures and so he knew that uh Seal
Team one was kind of regarded as like
the strict of the SEAL
Teams I remember at some point he had
this back in the '90s mhm back in the
90s he like saw some picture and it was
some seal and he had like a
skateboard sticker on his gear right
Skull Skates by the way I don't know if
they're still around but he was kind of
like well that's kind of crazy I go yeah
it's not they're not from Seal Team One
you I kind of was like hey bro we're not
doing that over here so this friend was
asking me do you think you'd be the same
if you didn't go to won and the answer
to me is no which seems obvious because
I was young and impressionable
impressionable and malleable as a
19-year-old buds graduate checking in to
team
one but I was also and this is sort of
just the kind of known factors of my
life is I was a rebellious kid I have a
rebellious streak I've always had a
rebellious streak I have that
psychological reactance don't like to
get told what to do I've told the story
about the fact that when I joined the
Navy my dad was like you're going to
hate it cuz you hate Authority and you
don't like listening to people he's 100%
right he was 100% right so I was a
rebellious from birth had that
rebellious strength I grew up I was way
into hardcore music very rebellious
attitude the hardcore attitude listen to
crom mags listen to Bad Brains listen to
Agnostic Front that's what I was
doing antisocial antisocial I was
outside the realm
and
so what turns out or the way it turned
out I think I actually got what I needed
from Seal Team one I think that if I
would have been at a team that had
inherently a more rebellious
attitude I would have been totally out
of control I would have taken that be
like oh that's what we're doing okay I
got it so if I went to a team that would
have been more
laidback I would have been like oh it's
cool to have long hair cool oh it's cool
to be a biker cool oh we're fighting
everyone like okay right on and look SE
Team all the seil teams had some of that
stuff going on but when I went to team
one there was at least a at that time
there was an underlying culture of
military professionalism like an
underlying culture I mean I when we got
there we were going on our first run as
new guys and one of my buddies wore a
visor you know what a visor is it's like
a hat without a thing yeah without the
top yeah at the top yeah well that's not
part of military uniform and the master
chief Master Chief of the command so
like the senior enlisted guy there sees
him walks up to him and says like if you
ever wear a visor again at Seal Team 1
I'm gonna have you sent to the
fleet I was like God like that was
insane like thinking about getting sent
to the fleet after you graduated from
Buds and checked into a team and now
you're getting sent to the fleet like
this is insane and he's and he's a mass
Chief and he means it he wasn't like
trying to be hyperbolic he was serious
like I will send you to the fleet if I
ever see you wearing a my
again so military professionalism was
held in high regard and there's a chance
that I could have like rebelled against
that like this place sucks but like no
because I was it's weird I was
rebellious but I was also young and
malleable like okay that's that's what
the master chief is saying that's what
we're doing we're wearing the right
uniform that's
so I think it helped
me and this is what I was thinking about
that after my buddy asked me this
question if I would have been the
authoritarian type it would have been
better for me to go to a team that was a
little bit more laxed and a little bit
more open-minded about things because
essentially what I think happens
is in the teams the way you now look the
teams are all kind of the same now
they're very much more the same than
they used to be not that they were all
like totally different but there's a
definitely you had a culture at each one
of the teams MH and now the teams are
much more the same because people get
switched more like youed to like I I
spent freaking seven years at Seal Team
One like seven years bro I mean I got
there and just stayed there and that was
very common there was a lot of guys they
were just team one guys there was team
Five Guys there was team three guys out
on the East Coast there was guys there
was guys when I got to team two there
was guys that have been in Seal Team 2
for like 20 years bro they were in in
the game they weren't going anywhere
wait so you can just so it's more you
think it's more common to jump not jump
but just nowadays you you'll do like two
tours at team one two tours at Team
three two tours at Team five or two T
tours at Team eight then you'll go and
you'll do like you'll go to trading
trade that then you go back to and you
won't be like all like dude I'm not I'm
waiting to go to to team one no one's
saying that they're like oh I can get
orders I can do a platoon Chief or I can
do my lpo slot over at Team two cool
I'll go they're not likey I want to go
to this team they don't really care as
much as they used to again the teams
there's still obviously tradition and
history at the teams but it's not as
there's not as much of the differenti
differentiating culture as there used to
be but this is the thing that I think is
cool is if you if
you leaders that want to control
everything you will find out that you
can't control everything M and that's a
positive thing the other end of the
spectrum is leaders that want to pull
the that don't want to pull the reins in
and just kind of like oh I'm kind of
laid back I'm just everyone's cool
eventually you'll watch things get
totally out of
control so depending on the type of
leader that you
are it's good to go into the environment
that's the opposite you see what I'm
saying so if I would have been like a
super crazy leader or a just a crazy guy
it was and I kind of was a little bit
right I was kind of rebellious I went to
team one it was very good for meh if I
would have been like a like a very
militant person that was like oh I went
to a military school it probably would
have been better for me to go to another
team where it's like hey dude you need
to chill out like occasionally they
would take guys and they'd send them
officers they'd send them to Ranger
school and Ranger school is totally
militant totally strict and sometimes
they would come out of that and it would
enhance their militaristic attitude and
you'd be like bro this ain't the Rangers
yeah yeah like you don't we're not doing
that and some guys were so wild you'd
have to send him to Ranger school and it
was good for him because like bro this
is the military yeah you're not just
able to do whatever you want so I got
put into an environment as a rebellious
cocky kid that kind of corrected that
attitude and if I would have been a
militaristic
tyrant if I would have been a
militaristic tyrant type of guy
mhm team one would have been good for me
me in the short term like like I would
have been like heck yeah and then I
would have been the type person that's
like hey you need to get a haircut right
and I was never like that even though I
came from Team One and even though like
in task un Bruiser was like hey we need
to wear square to wear uniforms I did it
for the mission I wasn't doing it for my
own authority you see what I'm saying
there's a huge difference yeah like when
we were on Camp Markle I didn't care
what you were I didn't care at all I
don't care what uniform I wasn't like
hey Le when you come into my office to
talk to me you better be in a freaking
uniform no like dude you roll in with
flipflops shf shorts shirt is optional
like we're in the team bro I don't care
when we go out and talk to a battalion
Commander be freaking squared away
that's the way it is but if someone has
a militaristic tyranical attitude it
might be good for them in the short term
because they fit in but in the long term
in the long term it doesn't develop them
as a person
yeah so I had kind of an open
mind
and team one focused my mind a little
bit right if I would have had a closed
mind it would have been better for me to
go to a team where the atmosphere opened
up my mind and the reason that I'm
saying all this this is a long way of me
for me to get to this point is that it's
good to put yourself in environments
that challenge you and your belief
systems yeah it's good to put yourself
in that type of environment now that
being said there is a I just got lucky
that I got sent to team one yeah no one
was like let's do a personality
assessment of jonco oh this guy listens
to freaking hardcore and punk rock music
and he's a wild kid and we we need to
give him some more military they didn't
say that they just randomly I got team
one me and GIF going over to team one
actually a bunch of guys from my class
went to Team One um and a bunch of guys
went to other teams as well but what I'm
saying is so you don't necessarily get a
chance to select your environment but
pay attention to if you are comfortable
in that environment because if you're
comfortable in that environment it may
not be conducive to your own growth as a
person you may be you know with like
we're doing Jiu-Jitsu yeah and there's
like a class where they're doing a lot
of takedowns MH and you're like dude I
love takedowns I wrestled in high school
this is awesome you're stoked right but
once you get to the ground hey we're
just going to stand it back up you're
kind of stoked on that so you go to that
class more often that's what I'm saying
what you need to do is you need to go
get engaged in those classes where
they're doing a lot of ground workor or
vice versa you're like hey dude I'm a
jiujitsu GU I'm not a wrestler well okay
let you need still need to get some
takedowns on so you can't just conform
and accept what feels
good you need to push back on yourself
you need to feel some resistance in the
world and if you can't if you don't feel
any resistance in the at atmosphere that
you're at that you're in then you need
to check it and make sure you develop
some resistance and you think about
things from an outside perspective that
you detach so that you can use that
resistance you might have to create some
resistance like hey man look I I know I
could just skip the warm-up and skip the
takedown part of this class but that's
not the right thing to do yeah I can do
it but it's not the right thing to do
you know I'm going to get in there I'm
going to make it happen I mean that's
what we want to do we use that
resistance to get better because we
don't improve if we are staying in an
environment that's not forcing us to
reassess where we're at kind of a long
way for me to say that but yeah does
that make sense oh yeah fully so you
know how and I guess the the what's the
idea right the saying there's no growth
in the comfort zone but that you're this
is interesting I never really thought
about this until right now like this
very specific thing it might have been
came in my mind before but not really
think about it where you're talking
about from a physical perspective like
physically placing yourself in an
environment or being in an environment
that challenges you outside of your
comfort zone like even like a dayto day
or just like just in life you see what
I'm saying you ever watched the movie
American History X yes good that was a
solid one so so remember right where uh
what was what was his name started with
a d right was it Darren or I don't know
the main character Ed Norton Ed Norton
yeah so he go he goes to jail you know
and he's a white supremacist dude he
goes to jail and he does not like black
people at all dislikes obviously white
supremacist you know the gig all right
so he goes and he gets paired up in the
laundry room right with a black guy and
this black guy's like kind of on the
surface like real stereotypical he's
talking a lot he's doing all this stuff
and he's like he doesn't like him he
won't even say one word to him but he
has to work in that environment got to
work with him so over time because the
guy's talking he's making jokes all this
stuff over time he kind of like
essentially in a nutshell slowly opens
his mind slowly opens his mind maybe
these black people aren't as bad as I
thought kind of a thing this here's OB
you know this one right here he's making
jokes we're actually and they become
friends and his mind slowly gets open he
gets to stretch like that you what I'm
saying but physically being in that
environment you're right man you're
right it's funny like with I used to go
um to competition training with Dean
lisst at other schools and that's kind
of the same gig where you know when
you're a stranger in a oh yeah they're G
to bring that heat oh they're bring that
heat if you're a teammate if you're
target practice like you're a Target you
might as well just be a grappling dummy
yeah and there's more stuff on the line
too so like think about it in your back
in our competition days you come to the
main spot you come to victory for
competition training you know the guy
I'm Joo Andy all these guy know these
guys you know there's no there's an
element of comfort in that no matter how
hard the training is but you go to the
if you're a stranger in another you know
Academy and they're doing competition
training that level of comfort is gone
straight up gone but you get used to it
and you can actually feel it when you go
back home to Victory you're kind of like
oh this is like real kind of cruise it's
easier to be honest with you and it's
more from a mental standpoint it's
easier unless you're a foreigner coming
into Victory and then you're like oh
these guys are out the camp oh right
which is the same gig just flipped
around yeah exactly right so yeah you
apply that kind of in life where yeah
put yourself in those physical
physically put yourself in those the the
weird thing too is and we covered this
on the psychology of military
incompetence but a lot of times people
that are attracted
to that is a little excerpt of what we
are doing on the Joo underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Joo underground.com And subscribe and
we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us strengthen
this Legion of Troopers that are in the
game with us so thank you it's Joo
underground.com it cost
$818 a month and if you can't afford to
support us we can still support you just
email assistance atjo underground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then we will see you
mobilized on
Underground